I would like to get serious for just a
moment if you're okay with that recently
at one of his rallies Donald Trump made
a comment in which he referred to one of
his supporters as quote my African
American yeah well ladies and gentlemen
as a friend to many African Americans
and an ally in the struggle against
racism I took great offense to this I
would never single out an African
audience and I'm sorry an African
American in my audience to quote the
great W EBD boys either the United
States will destroy ignorance or
ignorance will destroy the United States
you see I believe deep in my not this
again what does a guy that white know
about being black yeah Kona's never
singled out an african-american in his
audience because there's never been an
african-american in his audience
if he's so enlightened
why does cotan think kanye west is a
small country in africa conan so white
cops pull him over to give him Pinkberry
gift cards plus she thinks all black
people know each other
Cohen is always asking me if I'm friends
with Cleveland from family he calls the
police every time he sees a commercial
with the Old Spice guy yeah Conan's
really great with the only band in late
night where the two black guys have to
sit in the back row
me I'm black all part of that beautiful
mosaic that is mankind thank you very
much
[Applause]
you